this totally kept me guessing the entire
time there's so many surprises so i want
to know which one of you is just itching
to discuss some of those surprises
i think we both are
yeah both are but can't yeah it's just
frustrating because i i know rachel
we're
we like we love the movie so much and
it's so it's as you know it's fun to
talk about i think it's a movie that's
going to get people talking and it's
going to generate a lot of discussion
but um
and our job is to talk about it here
but we can't
it's a strange position to be in
yeah so some of the things we can talk
about by georgina i like that tess she's
a smart woman she asks all the right
questions but this audience is going to
be yelling at her do not go in that
house do not go down the stairs what are
you doing in that situation are you
going in the airbnb are you going into
the basement
um
i mean am i going no i probably would
not have got in the airbnb at all um i i
the idea of even yeah like being in an
airbnb with a random person is way too
much for me
but i think there's there's lots of
reasons why tess ends up doing what
she's doing and she has lots of moments
that are relatable that i can relate to
where she kind of tries to get out of
the situation and then pulled back in or
you know there's something that blocks
her so um i think there are many reasons
why she does what she does
and then justin for you is aj again i
don't want to give too much away but
your character's not a great guy maybe
but he doesn't think he doesn't think
he's not a good guy how would you
describe him
um
yeah he's definitely flawed but he
doesn't like like a lot of narcissists
he is um
he is not accountable for his flaws and
um and for the pain that he's caused
others he's just not accountable and um
yeah he has glimpses like little
glimmers of um
accountability and and
um
but uh without giving too much away
those are just little
little moments but he's audi it's not
giving much away as soon as you meet my
character within the first couple of
seconds you kind of know that he's um
he's a he's a pretty douchey
he's douchey
and when you're playing a guy like that
do you need to find some sort of
humanity to connect with him to make
people care
you have to yes i mean
yeah you have to um
find
what in whatever way you can uh ways to
relate and um
yes i think we all and and in this i
think i i love the idea of
how a lot of people perform in life and
this guy is just uh
he's presenting as cool or
he's more of a he's more performative
than a lot of people um so in that sense
i i you know i tried to relate to that
um
but there were certain things that he
did that
fortunately i couldn't relate to um so i
had to
just create
use my imagination uh he does some
pretty horrible things as you know
uh that's it we're already out of time i
cannot wait for more people to see this
so you know we can we can discuss it
more and then see that audience reaction
because i think it's going to be it's
going to be great oh it's so fun to see
and see within all with the as you know
you know to see what the theater is the
way to not with the theater with a
theater full of people
you